In this video we're going to talk about electromagnetic waves.
What are electromagnetic waves?
Well, for starters, they're waves.
And what is a wave?
A wave is a disturbance that can carry energy from one place to another.
So here's an example of a wave.
Like all waves, electromagnetic waves, they have amplitude,
they have wavelength, and also frequency.
Electromagnetic waves, they propagate at the speed of light,
which is 3 times 10 to the 8 meters per second.
This speed is equal to the wavelength of the wave times the frequency.
So when the wavelength decreases, the frequency of the wave increases.
The frequency is inversely related to the period of a wave.
The period is the time it takes for the wave to complete one cycle.
The frequency is the number of cycles that it can make in one second.
The unit of frequency is the hertz, and for period it's in seconds.
The energy of an electromagnetic wave is equal to Planck's constant times the frequency.
Planck's constant is 6.626 times 10 to the negative 34,
joules times seconds.
Now, there's a lot of different types of waves in nature.
Think of an ocean wave.
You know, it has a crest, it has a trough.
Think of a wave on a string.
But an electromagnetic wave is different.
This type of wave is composed of electric, eminetic fields.
Thus, we have the name electromagnetic waves.
And let's draw it.
So we're going to draw a 3D coordinate system.
My drawing is not perfect, but I'm going to make the best of it.
So first, let's draw the electric field component of an EM wave.
The electric field oscillates up and down.
We'll call this axis time.
Now, when the electric field is changing, it will create a change in magnetic field.
And the change in magnetic field, in turn, will create a change in electric field.
And so, when you're dealing with an EM wave, you have an electric field on an axis
and perpendicular to it.
You have a magnetic field.
We'll call it B.
So that is an electromagnetic wave.
On one axis, you have the electric field, which are oscillating.
And on another axis, perpendicular to it, you have oscillating magnetic fields.
The electric field is equal to the speed of light times the strength of the magnetic field.
Electromagnetic waves can be created by any type of charge particle.
A charge particle always has an electric field around it.
A moving charge particle can create a magnetic field.
But an accelerating charge particle can create a propagating electromagnetic wave.
Here's another example.
So let's say we have a hydrogen atom.
And let's say this is the first energy level.
This one is the second.
And let's say this is the third energy level.
Let's say we have an electron, an excited electron, in a third energy level.
When the electron drops from the third energy level to the second energy level,
or even lower than that,
any time it goes from a high energy level to a low energy level,
it can emit an electromagnetic wave.
Sometimes it can emit a full ton of light.
Now for the hydrogen atom, the energy of the full ton that's emitted is equal to negative 2.18 times 10 to the negative 18 joules,
times 1 over n final squared minus 1 over n initial squared,
where n is the energy level of the electron.
This is the initial energy level.
In this case that will be n equal 3.
This is the final energy level.
That's where it's going to n equal 2.
When an electron absorbs a full ton,
it can jump from a low energy state to a high energy state.
But when it falls from a high energy state to a low energy state,
it can release a full ton in the form of an electromagnetic wave.
But now only that though,
when electrons are oscillating within the metal,
they can also emit electromagnetic waves.
Even when they're heated,
if you were to heat up metal to a very high temperature,
eventually the metal will appear in red hot.
At this point,
it's emitted in infrared radiation and even in red light as well.
As you raise the temperature,
it'll produce light through incandescence.
It'll appear yellow.
If you raise it even further,
it'll appear bright white.
When the temperature is high,
the atoms are oscillating,
the electrons are oscillating,
and they're emitting electromagnetic waves.
Any time a charged particle is experiencing acceleration,
whether it's moving from a high energy state to a low energy state
or if it's oscillating,
it can emit an EM wave.